all right guys you are singing on a song
with Beyonce so you know what are these
albums coming out we're waiting for her
to get back to uh oh yeah yeah right a
deal based on our title release a rap
album are you gonna sing is gonna be pop
country like what are we going look
forward spoken words
slam poetry slam poetry yeah kind of a
William Shatner thing yeah but about
Hanukkah yeah
only about Hanukkah were Jewish exactly
oh Hanukkah spoken word slam poetry oh
yeah you guys have been discussing this
oh yeah it seems yeah the tonic is like
the last thing Beyonce hasn't done
exactly so it's time probably do it
better than most you can do it all yeah
yeah this movie is great I mean the
original was awesome but this is even I
mean more fun and you two really you're
really hilarious thank you
was it as much fun to make as it was for
me just watching I hope so it was a lot
of fun yeah we got to perform together
in the recording booth which is rare oh
and I think you could tell it we really
were able to play off of each other and
and respond to one another in in real
time which I think again in a movie like
this that is so technical especially
like you don't get that very often so it
was it was nice good to do that that's
awesome it was amazing I mean we had
such a good time of course you have
nerve-racking moments you know there's
pressure to get it right obviously
people love the original and we want to
do our spin on it but um once we got in
the room jon favreau created a really
warm collaborative environment and it
was just about finding the best jokes
and really working together as a team
and that was really fun John was telling
me that he was actually jealous of you
playing the pig well I'm jealous of him
directing the line
I was like a dream of is nobody I'd like
to direct a Marvel films will exchange
it for one point exactly yeah if you
could pick one of Beyonce songs to
represent Timon and represent Pumbaa
what song would you pick and why for
Pumbaa it's for sure bootylicious that's
a good you ready yeah he's a plump sexy
little creature yeah Timon I don't know
why I'm going to say all the single in
your life are you most excited about
watching this film god I think about
that my agents yeah exactly
ya know they really need to see me in a
mainstream exactly other Disney
executives people a whole team exactly
as they roll out phase whatever the
Marvel Universe there's probably more
characters like apparent managers agents
lawyers yeah maybe some executives at
Paramount see perfect I mean I know you
took your nephews right I did yes
they enjoyed it very much it was lovely
to take them my actually one of my
nephew's was at the premiere for this as
the end he was a baby though but he
didn't remember but it was nice to take
me to a film they could actually watch
yeah I mean it's pretty cool to be in
the film but then to also sing in the
film I mean you're cool to someone yeah
who is there kids sir animals
I mean someone who are you cool too
right now who am i cool to like who's
like most excited about this oh I mean
everyone I know is pretty excited about
it
honestly uh family friends it's a huge
movie I mean it's a real you know the
way you say that you guys are hilarious
anyway thank you so much
you have a good one thank you